[Applause]
crazy crazy no tie
happy friday everyone
what a week huh
if you're a fan of liberal meltdowns
well kids this is your super bowl
wrapped in a world series with a stanley
cup chaser
it's all sports stuff
first the supreme court strikes down new
york state's regulations for concealed
carry pistol permits which allows all
right
lots of murderers in the office in the
audience but that allows more
law-abiding americans the right to carry
in public spaces where not so
law-abiding citizens are already doing
the same
funny how libs aimed at packing the
court and now the court is packing the
public
we go to the nra for comment
meanwhile the gun control libs took it
well
[Applause]
yeah the frantic miserable takes came in
hotted heavy but you may not notice
since these freaks are miserable all the
time but man do they hate it when law
abiding people finally get the same
protections as thugs apparently the left
worries that those poor felons might get
shot when they're trying to shoot you
remember it's these idiots who push for
defunding of the police and gun control
at the same time like an intern for
andrew cuomo he gets squeezed at both
ends
i don't get it
i don't write this stuff it's disgusting
the system won't protect you and neither
can you you're like a kidnapping victim
after the search for you has been called
off
but you can see why the left is pissed
crime doesn't affect them they live in
nice places have private security so no
wonder this dolt finds it shocking
absolutely shocking
shocking
absolutely shocking i'm sorry this dark
day has come
i'd ask what world she's been living in
mostly because her eyebrows look like
aliens
here's our new york mayor this decision
has made every single one of us less
safe from gun violence and we cannot
allow new york to become the wild wild
west
that's an insult to the era and the will
smith movie
and the tv show the wild wild west has
this guy ever been to east new york it's
way past the wild wild west john wayne's
horse would be stripped to its hooves in
five minutes
if he rode through there
[Laughter]
look i want to give you a chance mayor
but guns don't kill people politicians
who don't do to keep violent criminals
off the street kill people
yes
yes
applaud away i deserve it when you were
campaigning for mayor you were always
described as a law and order guy we
didn't know they meant it's your
favorite tv show
maybe instead of going to the gala at
the met dressed like p daddy's butler
do your job
okay
god i hope kamala is deeply concerned
and troubled
we the president myself many of us are
deeply
concerned and troubled by the supreme
court's ruling today
it it i believe defies common sense
and um the constitution that
yeah right
okay i'm talking common sense is like
cat talking nuclear fission
greg
nuclear fission is just a reaction where
the nucleus of an atom splits into two
or more smaller nuclei which releases a
huge amount of energy even by the
energetic standards of radioactive decay
gonna have to rethink my thoughts on
kamala
fair enough and what of poor lori
lightfoot
the fact that the court is coming down
with this decision feels tone death and
i i worry that it undermines the
legitimacy
of the court
sorry lady but i also hear gunshots make
you tone deaf
maybe you see a doctor before diagnosing
this decision you gave up on fighting
crime in the most violent city in the
country just banned cops from chasing
perps so you have no voice in this
matter and please as a medical
professional get some sleep
[Laughter]
i wonder
i wonder is joe disappointed in the
supreme court gun decision
i am disappointed in the supreme court
conversation i think it's a bad decision
i think it's and i think it's
not reasoned accurately but i'm
disappointed yeah he's disappointed
because he thought matlock was on
but at least he knows how we feel about
him
disappointed i bet the view don't even
have the words it seems
i don't even have the words it seems
stupid
no it's worse than that it's worse than
that it's not even stupid it is it's
it's
no it's it's so it's such a middle
finger to new york
no it's a supreme court flipping you off
but screw them all
not literally that's disgusting
here's why they didn't care about the
riots they saw them as justifiable they
didn't care about black on black crime
because it embarrassed their own
sequestered lives and their own
obliviousness to the consequences of
their crappy policies they created the
crime and now they're mad people want to
defend themselves and they think that if
we just sit there and be victims we'll
eventually all be democrats
so you can't have it both ways you can't
do nothing to protect us and then
prevent us from protecting ourselves
especially when it's our right
and dare i say god-given
look
it's amazing i'm agnostic except you gun
control jerks made me into a believer
if i have to listen to one more vapid
gun control idea the next time you'll
see me i'll be wearing a clerical collar
besides my abs are proof there's a god
but you defund the police let out repeat
offenders reduce penalties for gun crime
the only thing left is the second
amendment
look the first amendment is enumerated
meaning i don't need paperwork to tell
you to go screw yourself the second
amendment is also enumerated it's a
right that's inalienable
which is hard to say drunk
too many vowels
but it also means you can't infringe on
it and now we have roe v wade overturned
and here's the obvious one sentence
explanation guns are in the constitution
abortion isn't you can love it or hate
it but it's hard to argue that point and
i get it not everyone should have guns
but
but this wouldn't be a problem had these
liberal a-holes done their job instead
of siding with the thugs they let people
out because they said it was racist to
keep them in then looked the other way
when minority neighborhoods were
destroyed due to their stupid policies
they made this crime ridden bad true
we'll all still need to apply for a gun
permit but we sure as hell don't need
your permission anymore so as one famous
cop once said go ahead make my day it
looks like the supreme court just did
[Applause]
welcome
tonight
yes
she only sweats the big stuff because by
comparison it's all big stuff co-host of
the five in america's newsroom data
burrito
she's the money maven whose hair is not
raven
[Music]
host of the evening edit on fox business
liz mcdonald
he's got three names one for himself and
another two for each bicep retired u.s
marine corps bomb technician and fox
news contributor johnny joey jones
and she's like a hotel reservation from
yesterday already checked out
fox news contributor cat tim
so dana which one would you like to
tackle you wanted to i mean you know uh
the the
roe v wade thing just happened and uh so
i don't know what's your feeling well i
think one you pointed out very
succinctly and i think this is the key
thing to know is that yesterday when the
gun case came out the democrats and
liberals people who were against that
decision were like how dare they and
then today they're using their same
arguments to say how dare they on roe v
wade because they're trying to make the
same argument right because basically as
you pointed out
and the second amendment is clear
and even though new york can have a law
on its books for 100 years that doesn't
mean it was constitutional right and so
now you have a court that is willing to
go there and also gun rights act
activists had told people well activists
people that support gun rights had said
you better not bring this case to the
supreme court because you're going to
lose that's what they were telling to
the gun control people they brought it
anyway and now they've lost i do think
when whippy goldberg says that it's like
actually
the
alvin bragg and the prosecutors like
gascon and krasner that's flipping off
the citizens who are have a contract
with you in order to take care of them
then on the other side
abortion is nowhere in the constitution
there isn't there's no third amendment
it doesn't say the fourth amendment it's
not about abortion and so now it doesn't
mean that there is no abortion ever in
the united states it means the states
get to now have a shot at it if you live
in new york state
nothing changes for you right live in
california nothing changes for you
except for gavin newsom wants to make
california an abortion destination which
if you're working in the tourism bureau
you probably never thought you would
make up your uh like a brochure yes for
that oh my god i'm not taking that
cruise that's right so um
there are a lot of um
there's a lot of misconceptions there's
a lot of hyperbole there's a lot of
media misconceptions it's going to
continue but i also both point out one
last thing if people think this will
change anything in the midterms i think
that they're wrong in virginia when
the
remember the young can yeah win
60 of people who said that abortion was
their number one issue
and terry mccullough tried to make that
an issue in virginia sixty percent of
them voted for yonkin
so i don't necessarily think that this
gets the democrats where they wanna be
electorally they voted for young kin
then
the supreme court voted for young kin i
should have come up with that i really
really
verbal
verbal acuity like you've never seen
before
joey
great to see you you're the gun expert
judging by your biceps
yeah i'd like to hang those on my wall
i'd like to put those in my gun safe
yeah listen um
you're not gonna do it you're not gonna
do it
um i can't tyrus isn't here to make
uncomfortable so it's you listen uh
thank god
thank god donald trump was president for
four years
all right
was that a clap for you are you gonna do
that i know
no but this is like red meat friday
we you know it's the opposite of vegan
friday you just throw red meat out under
eight years of obama it was the
democrats practice to throw it to the
supreme court if we can't get the
support right when you worry about these
issues guns or abortion those are issues
that truly have divided us or we are
divided and these issues have come to
light as americans the reason why we're
divided we have two very different
experiences listen we live in a country
that will let you go be the king or
queen of your castle if you cho if you
so choose but also if you choose to be a
part of the hive and an aunt and anton
hill you can move to new york
but those rights stay the same just
because they're more pragmatic in
georgia than they are here to some
politicians doesn't mean that they
somehow go away because you move here
and there's seven million people in a
place where there should be seven
thousand that's not that's not the
constitution's fault
all right so when we talk about guns in
new york the reason why i leave my door
unlocked 25 minutes south of atlanta is
not because there's no vagrance around
this because every vagrant in my county
knows they're probably going to get shot
right if they come in not just my house
but any house there is a part of our
culture
american culture is gun culture it's
part of who we are it's part of the
fabric that put this country together
when you compare us to the wild wild
west well what was the wild wild west it
was the taming of the wild wild
and we and we had to have a gun on our
side to have order in the streets yeah
all right well that's what this is
because the police aren't putting order
on the streets there aren't enough of
them there aren't enough people in this
city that would want to do the job much
less be compensated for it to get rid of
the crime that's here because of the
policies they have ushered the crime in
so it's a problem people have the basic
right to defend themselves in a
bureaucrat deciding what day they're
going to work and who should or
shouldn't get to carry a firearm based
on how well they argued their danger you
don't carry a firearm because somebody's
trying to kill you you carry a firearm
so nobody ever does right there you go
what do you think liz
you're packing right now right yeah not
like joey is
those are some guns over there um
you know sleeves for now you know just
to defund the police push and i i always
wonder why how come it's not considered
a civil rights violation to let a felon
out of a prison who kills an innocent
person right you know so it's so where
was that so and then you know just
looking at the whole debate when it
comes to how they're going to handle it
in new york
you know the permitting process is going
to be stuck right right so when you
think about it you would you would
sooner have an obituary written about
you that get your apartment renovated
right yes because it takes years so
they're probably going to have this
stuck in that process for a very long
time but you know there is you know the
george will have that column maybe he's
talking about it there's a trade-off
between
you know the second amendment public
safety the framers wanted both there is
a concern about that right right people
want to feel safe in new york you don't
know who's sitting next to you on the
subway with a gun right so there's that
issue and i think that's a serious one
when it comes to abortion you know i
always wondered you know 100 countries
have over-the-counter birth control
right and so there is an issue about
that you don't want unwanted teen
pregnancies they could be misused that
that's an issue too but i always
wondered if men could get pregnant there
might be chocolate covered advil in a
four-day work week right now i don't
know but you know so so there are
serious issues yeah of course and it's
it's wild that they did it back to back
in two days right and you know who's out
of the country right now is attorney
general merrick garland so why i don't
understand why he's out of the country
yeah he's waiting for you right now he's
in ukraine yeah there you go there's
your answer cat you know as a future
supreme court justice
were they correct
on the uh second amendment you think
obviously yeah i mean i've i've never
understood how it was new york was able
to have the laws that it has i mean if i
have a right to self-defense that means
i have a right to a gun yeah i don't
look like joey like
like i could be so easily murdered that
it's like like it's like you wouldn't
even you know what i mean like you could
even use your bare hands probably just
kill me
these are things you shouldn't brag
about no i mean just look at me
everybody already knows that probably
some of them are probably thinking about
it
you know
so i i i should i'm so excited about
this i want to get a gun i want to get
so many guns i wish
i'm going to be one of those girls where
guns becomes my whole personality
i'm gonna turn to one of those i wish
that real estate was like a little
cheaper because i'm gonna need more room
for all my just arsenal of weapons yes
let's go yes amen
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else